>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C...
>> Karen Jaffe: Morning, I'm Karen
Jaffe of the Young Reader Center
and this is a special story
time on Friday, April,
8th to celebrate 150th anniversary
of "Alice in Wonderland".
How many know who "Alice
in Wonderland" is?
Well, you're going to
find out very soon.
I just have a few things to
share with you before we begin.
After the program, which is
going to be about 30 minutes,
we're going to have
a special parade,
so you will be following our
storyteller Caroline Quandt
and a special guest
storyteller who will be our
"Alice" this morning,
Joani Etskovitz.
And I just want to remind everybody
when we start the parade you will
all, all the grown-ups will have had
to fill out a photo release form,
so if you have not done that,
you will have to do that
before you join the parade
because we have video
and we have photography,
and we need that document
for the library.
So now I'm going to
introduce Caroline Quandt,
the YRC storyteller.
>> Caroline Quandt: Hey everybody.
Time for stories, time for
stories, oh it's story time again.
Let us gather altogether as
we sit beside our friends.
Time for stories, time for
stories, oh it's story time again.
Let us gather altogether as
we sit beside our friends.
Good morning everybody and
welcome to the Young Reader Center
and happy birthday
"Alice", yeah, alright.
So let's do Open Shut Them
to wake up our brains, okay?
Open, shut them, open, shut them,
give a little clap, clap, clap.
put them in your lap, lap, lap.
Creep them, crawl them,
creep them, crawl them,
right up to your chin, chin, chin.
Open wide your little mouth
but do not let them in.
One more time.
Open, shut them, open, shut them,
give a little clap, clap, clap.
put them in your lap, lap, lap.
Creep them, crawl them,
creep them, crawl them,
right up to your chin, chin, chin.
Open wide your little mouth
but do not let them in.
Good job, okay.
Can you clap with two
hands, two hands, two hands.
hands, clap, clap, clap.
Can you kick with two
feet, two feet, two feet?
Can you kick with two feet,
kick, kick, kick, kick, kick?
Can you sway side to side,
side to side, side to side?
sway, sway, sway, sway, sway?
Can you kiss with two
lips, two lips, two lips?
lips, [inaudible]?
We are all so happy, happy, happy.
We are all so happy
to be with you today.
We are all so happy, happy, happy.
We are all so happy
to be with you today.
[inaudible], alright.
So let's give a big hand for Joani
Etskovitz who's come all the way
from her college at Princeton to
give us this wonderful story time
with "Alice in Wonderland".
Come on up Joanie.
Oh, isn't she lovely,
here's "Alice".
Alright. Okay, "Mr. Mad
Hatter" has taken off.
>> Joani Etskovitz:
Well, welcome everybody.
Thank you for coming
to my story time today.
How many of you have heard of
my adventures in Wonderland?
Some of you.
Well today I'm going to
get to tell you about them.
My good friend Lewis Carroll
wrote me a story called
"Alice's Adventures in Wonderland"
and it begins with the rabbit hole.
I was beginning to get very tired
of sitting by my sister on the bank
and of having nothing to do.
Once or twice, I had peeped into
the book that my sister was reading
but it had no pictures and
no conversations in it.
"And what is the use
of a book", I thought,
"without pictures or conversations?"
So I was considering in my
own mind as well I could
for the hot day made me feel
very sleepy and very stupid,
whether the pleasure of making
a daisy chain would be worth the
trouble of getting up
and picking the daisies
when suddenly a white rabbit
with pink eyes ran close by me.
There is nothing so very remarkable
in that nor did I think it,
"[inaudible], we have
a little rabbit here."
Nor did I think it so very much out
of the way to hear the rabbit say
to itself, "Oh, dear, oh, dear.
I shall be too late."
Well, when I thought about it
afterwards, it occurred to me
that I ought to have
wondered at this
but at the time it had
all seemed quite natural.
But when the rabbit actually took
a watch out of its waistcoat pocket
and looked at it and hurried
on, I started to my feet
for it had flashed across my mind
that I had never before seen a
rabbit with either waistcoat pockets
or a watch to take out of it.
And burning with curiosity, I
ran across the field after it
and was just in time to see it pop
down a large rabbit
hole under the hedge.
In another moment, down I went
after it, never once considering how
in the world I was to get out again.
The rabbit hole went
straight on like a tunnel
for some way then dipped suddenly
down so that I had not a moment
to think before stopping myself.
And before I could stop
myself, I found myself falling
down what seems to
be a very deep well.
So as I was falling,
naturally I thought
to myself, "Well, why am I falling?
Why am I in a hole?
Where am I going?"
I was very confused, you see.
It's very puzzling to
fall for such a long way.
So I thought that it might
help to recite some lessons
to remember what I had taught,
perhaps remember something
that would help me.
And I thought of my lesson
about the little crocodile.
Have you learned that one?
Do you know the lesson
about the crocodile?
Oh, well it's very
important, everybody knows it,
so I will present for you?
Yes. And I do believe there's
a song to go along with it.
Let me see what's the tune?
[ Singing ]
[ Applause ]
So naturally, as the crocodile's
a creature of the water,
what I would find at
the bottom of my hole,
at the bottom of the
rabbit hole was a great sea.
And after swimming through it for
quite some time, I found myself
on an island with many
strange animals.
And as it is quite uncomfortable to
be wet in so many layers of fabric,
we had to find a way
to get ourselves dry.
And this is what we did.
Lewis Carroll wrote about
it in his Chapter 3,
A Caucus-Race and a Long Tale".
We were indeed were a queer-looking
party that assembled on the bank,
the birds with draggled feathers,
the animals with their fur
clinging close to them,
and all dripping wet cross
and quite uncomfortable.
The first question was, of
course, how to get dry again.
We had a consultation about this
and after a few minutes it
seemed quite natural to me
to find myself talking
familiar with them
as though I had known
them for all my life.
So my animal friends and I talked
about what we should do to get dry.
And my friend Mr. Dodo
gave a long speech
and everybody cut him off
but the Dodo spoke up.
"What I was going to stay" said
the dodo in an offended term "was
that the best thing to get us
dry would be a caucus race."
Now, who here knows
what a caucus race is?
>> Alligator.
>> Joani Etskovitz: An alligator.
Well, there was an
alligator involved
and we're going to
learn more about it.
"What is a caucus race?"
I asked, not that I
really wanted to know.
But the dodo had paused as if it
thought that somebody had ought
to speak and no one else seemed
inclined to say anything.
"Why?" said the dodo, "the best
way to explain is to do it."
And pay close attention as you might
like to try the thing yourself
some winter day or some spring day
in the Library of Congress.
I will tell you how the dodo
managed his caucus race.
First, the dodo marked out a
race course in a sort of circle.
"The exact shape doesn't
really matter."
it said. And then all the parties
were placed along the course here
and there.
There was no "one, two, three,
[inaudible]" but they began running
as they liked and left off when
they liked but it was not easy
to know when the race was over.
However, when they had been
running for half an hour or so
and were quite dry again,
the dodo suddenly called out,
"The race is over."
And all the crowd [inaudible]
and asked, "but who's won?"
This was a question that
the dodo could not answer
without a great deal of thought.
And it stood for a long time with
one finger pressed on its forehead;
you know the position in which
you usually see Shakespeare
in pictures of him?
Now the rest waited in silence.
At last, the dodo said, "Everybody
has won and all must have prizes."
Little did I know that when the
dodo said that all must have prizes,
I was expected to supply the prizes?
I had but a thimble in my pocket
but it functioned, it worked.
Everybody was very pleased
to receive my thimble.
And what I did next was I
went and continued my journey,
I met more animal friends.
I met a cat, the Cheshire
cat, perhaps you've heard
of him, my friend Cheshire?
Does anybody know Cheshire puss?
>> Yes.
>> Joanie Etskovitz:
You know Cheshire puss?
Well, excellent.
Well, what I said to him-- Darling,
would you like to come
sit by me in the front?
Would you like to sit with me?
Come and sit with me.
You can help me tell the story.
I have another Alice to
help me tell my story.
Would you like to come?
Oh, well you're welcome
to sit where you'd like.
One thing about Wonderland, we're
all mad here so there's no order.
So to the Cheshire cat, "Cheshire
puss", I began rather timidly
as I did not at all
know whether it would
like that name [inaudible]
grins a little wider.
It's a smiling cat.
[inaudible], it's pleased so
far, I thought, and I went on.
"Would you tell me, please, which
way I ought to go from here?"
for I was lost.
"That depends, a good deal" said
the cat, "on where you want to go."
"I don't much care where", I said.
"Then it doesn't matter which
way you go" said the cat.
"So long as I get somewhere."
I added as an explanation.
"Oh well, you're sure to
do that" said the cat,
"if you only walk long enough."
I felt that this could not be
denied, so I tried another question.
"Well, what sort of
people live about here?"
"Well, in direction", said the
cat waving its right paw around,
"lives a hatter.
Perhaps, you've seen the hatter?
And in that direction" waving the
other paw, "lives a large hare.
Visit either you like,
they're both mad."
"But I don't want to
go among mad people."
I remarked.
"Oh well, you can't help that."
said the cat "We're all mad here."
[ Background Sounds ]
I didn't think that
proved it at all.
However, I went on, "And how
do you know that you're mad?
"To begin with," said the
cat, "a dog is not mad.
You grant that?"
"I suppose so."
I said. "Well then", the cat
went on, "you see a dog growls
when it's angry [inaudible] and
wags its tail when it's pleased.
Now, I growl when I'm [inaudible]
and I wag my tail when I'm angry
and therefore, I am mad."
"I call it purring, not growling."
I said. "Call it what
you like" said the cat,
"Do you play croquet
with the queen today?"
"I should like it very much."
I said, "but I haven't
been invited yet.
"You'll see me there" said
the cat and he vanished.
So I followed the cat's direction
and I went to see the Mad Hatter
as much as I did not want
to go amongst mad people.
And while I was there, we had a
lovely tea party, a mad tea party.
And the Hatter sang us a song.
It was called, "Twinkle
Twinkle Little Bat" but I'm told
that that's not how it
goes in Washington, D.C.,
that it's different than
it is in Wonderland.
I'm told I hear you sing about
"Twinkle Twinkle Little Star?
Does anybody know that song?
You know that song?
You know that song,
too and you know it?
Oh well then perhaps you can teach
me so that I can learn how you sing
"Twinkle Twinkle in Washington.
Oh, it looks like my [inaudible].
Do you know this song; do you
know this "Twinkle Twinkle"?
[ Inaudible ]
Well perfect.
>> Caroline Quandt:
Let's all do it together.
>> Joani Etskovitz:
Would you like to sing?
>> Caroline Quandt: Alright,
going to do it twice, okay?
[inaudible].
Sorry, technical--
>> Joani Etskovitz: Well that
doesn't sound like "Twinkle".
>> We're mad here, remember?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Caroline Quandt: There we go.
Okay, ready?
Twinkle. Twinkle.
Twinkle, twinkle little star,
how I wonder what you are.
Up above the world so high,
like a diamond in the sky.
Twinkle, twinkle little star,
how I wonder what you are.
Okay, we're going to do it again.
[inaudible] keep twinkling.
You know those stars, they
never stop twinkling even
when it's light out, that's
right, they're still up there.
There we go.
Twinkle, twinkle little star,
how I wonder what you are.
Up above the world so high,
like a diamond in the sky.
Twinkle, twinkle little star,
how I wonder what you are.
[inaudible] alright.
And now we have our goodbye song.
Let's all give a wonderful
hand to "Alice" for coming
and sharing her mad story.
>> Joanie Etskovitz: Why, thank you.
>> The more we get
together, together, together,
the more we get together,
we're a little behind.
the happier we will be.
The more we get together,
together, together,
the more we get together,
the happier we'll be.
It's mad.
[ Inaudible ]
>> The more we get
together, together, together,
the more we get together,
the happier we'll be.
The more we get together, together,
together, the more we get together,
the happier we will be because
your friends are my friends
and my friends are your friends
and the more we get together,
the happier we will be.
>> Caroline Quandt: Oh yes, alright,
thank you so much for coming.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.